[Music]
there are five
statewide ballot questions on your
ballot this year these would make
changes to nevada's constitution
today we want to explain ballot question
number one to you
in order to get on the ballot they had
to already pass through the legislature
twice
back in 2017 and 2019
ballot question one is probably the most
confusing one
it would remove the board of regents
from the state constitution
the board of regents oversees nevada's
university system
critics say this has allowed the board
of regents to operate without any
oversight
from the legislature former assemblyman
elliot anderson wrote question one
that restores accountability
transparency and oversight
you know right now nevada spends 1.2
billion dollars on higher ed
but without any real oversight on how
that money is spent it would also
let the legislature create new rules and
laws overseeing
nevada's higher education system it's
really really important
for nevada and for our economy that our
higher ed system can be nimble
to answer the issues that we need to
deal with
question one has some opposition from
current members of the board of regents
but the argument against the passage on
the secretary of state's website says
question one is nothing but the
legislature trying to gain more power
and control
and it would only serve to add political
pressures to a governance system that is
serving this state well
now if question one is passed it would
take effect on november
24th of this year